We certainly choose each other according to self-awareness, awareness and intelligence.
And I do not, you know ... if you choose a partner
There is a race between humans when choosing the smartest partners
This is specifically the issue of women in their relationships with men
So the idea is that this is a choice, well this partly is why Eve makes Adam self conscious in the Garden of Eden
They offer him an apple. Is what makes him self-conscious, and I think that's true
Because the evidence of evolutionary biologists is that the sexual selection of female human
Was one of the factors that motivated us to change and differ from the shamanzi
It is a large factor and the female Shambanese is not optional when entering into the eugenics, they reproduce with anything
What happens is that the dominant males chase the male inferior, and therefore ends up leaving the descendants of Aktar !!
But it is not punishable by choice of females, in humans this is completely different
Invasive ovulation and intense selection of pressure on women by men.
You have twice the number of female ancestors of male ancestors.
People find it difficult to work on it arithmetically, but it is not that difficult,
You just think on average that every woman has one child, half men do not have, the other half has two.
This is almost true if you are averaging across the history of the entire human race.
Male males in particular are subject to strong selection pressure by females,
I also think that is partly why nature is represented symbolically as women among humans,
For in the end nature is chosen. There is no better definition of this nature